yo yo yo yo la paix et l'amour tout le monde la paix dans l'amour
ils ont
de la chance, il
y a un grand changement,
la zone est un peu comme le sacré, elle a
changé à cause de ce qui s'est passé, c'est
mettre un autre type d'esprit spirituel sur
la terre que vous savez avant, c'était juste une
zone où les gens visitaient des aliments coupés et
faisaient leur  routine quotidienne mais depuis la
mort de George et il était beaucoup de nos
frères amis, ça a changé donc
ça va être un endroit différent pendant
longtemps
[Musique]
Je voulais juste garder cette
communauté en sécurité et cet espace dit
parce que je  pensez à une face vraiment sacrée,
nous voulons nous assurer que cela
reste
ainsi  il y a encore beaucoup de travail
à faire
j'ai beaucoup pleuré je suis probablement
dans mon cœur je pleure en ce moment tu peux
faire le craquement dans ma voix et puis
c'est l'homme afro-américain qui aurait pu
être moi beaucoup  d'entre nous se font arrêter
vous savez
l'âme que Jorge a sacrifié sa vie et
cela signifie beaucoup pour beaucoup d'entre nous
frères vous connaissez beaucoup de gens et
c'est une bonne chose que l'Amérique voit maintenant
vous savez qu'ils ont ouvert ce livre pour
voir quoi  se passe vraiment dans une
vie d'Amérique noire
[Musique]